what's this
[Music]
what happened now
thank you
[Music]
foreign
we've just seen a new trailer for
updates coming to high fire Rush called
arcade challenge update no joke there's
literally exclamation points in there
that's not just me so here to explain
that and more about the update is game
director John Johannes welcome to
Showcase extended John really glad to be
here exclamation points
they have to be in there yeah it feels
the style it's style yeah it's a style
thing well Hi-Fi Rush is such a stylish
game in general I think that's one of
the things that people really excitedly
pointed out when we Shadow dropped the
game in the developer direct earlier
this year but making a brand new IP is
always a bit of a risk your studio is
known for kind of scarier games like The
Evil Within and ghostwired Tokyo can't
deny that
um but yeah this type of game is
something I just always wanted to make
personally and I just thought music and
action work so well together and after I
had finished working on The Evil Within
2 it just felt like the right time to
try something new and our studio has
always been about just making fun games
it doesn't have to be about a certain
genre we're not about making one
specific thing unfortunately there's
plenty more of that content to come
because we just saw an absolutely
jam-packed trailer so I'd love for your
help in breaking down all the details
all the stuff going into this update
sure there's a lot so bear with me
everything in this mode is unlockable
once you finish the game and you'll
unlock an arcade cabinet in your hideout
and by accessing it you get two new
modes one is called BPM Rush mode which
takes the gameplay up to like higher
speeds than we've ever done in the main
game and the other is called power up
Tower up which is a new sort of
randomized spin on the Rhythm Tower mode
that we have in the original game and
included in this mode are five new
original songs to play do as well as two
brand new enemies and then there's
special attacks and this whole meta
system for unlocking upgrades and
rewards and that's what I can think of
right now I love that there's so much to
to unpack there but let's rewind let's
talk about just BPM rush for now it was
described in the trailer as effectively
Hi-Fi Russia's equivalent of a turbo
mode can you explain that a little bit
more yeah early on the team was like how
fast can we go and in the game we kind
of settle that you know about a Max 160
BPM but this mode really takes it up to
200 BPM but we sort of ease you in there
it's a gradual upgrade until it
eventually gets so fast you just gotta
sort of think on your feet and naturally
react to the Rhythm in the combat of the
game I personally love that there's a
lot of accessibility settings in the
game too makes it so that you can adjust
the game to your own Comfort level but
this is a post game challenge it's meant
for when you've gotten into the rhythm
of the game so I'm curious if you have
any pointers on as far as how to tackle
that challenge as an action game I think
a lot of people want that sort of next
level challenge another way to use their
abilities in a new type of environment
this mode does that by putting you at
the high speed but we also have multiple
difficulties we have an easy mode for
people who want experience what that's
like but maybe are not in tune with that
sort of high difficulty that's
accompanied with this stuff but then we
have a casual normal mode as well and
then we have after beating those modes
we can unlock an ex mode which takes up
to a hard level where damage is
Multiplied and keeps you at that high
BPM through the entire time but there
already was a post game challenge when
Hi-Fi Rush launched it was the Rhythm
Tower mode you mentioned that briefly
earlier that's the one where you face
just increasingly different difficult
combat so how has that evolved with the
power of power up mode so the Rhythm
Tower mode was kind of like a very
curated experience and while it was very
challenging you can prepare go in and
sort of customize your character know
what you're getting into and in this
mode we flip it to the almost opposite
end chai starts off downgraded we
actually remove all your abilities and
you have to earn them back by fighting
waves of randomized enemy sets and after
every wave of enemies you get to choose
from a series of power-ups that can
gradually increase your stats each of
these upgrades comes with either bonus
or negative modifiers as well to the
gameplay so you can take more risks or
less risks depending on which upgrades
you pick and again those upgrades are
randomized each level so really kind of
an understanding of the systems and not
quite Master them but have a good grasp
if you want to go in and come out on top
well as I mentioned earlier it was a
really packed trailer there was a lot of
information in there it's a chunky
update so what else have you got for us
because I feel like there's more on the
table there yeah so by playing in the
two modes you unlock these rewards to
these challenges that are connected to
these two modes and in those rewards are
things like accessories for chai and new
costumes for chai 808 and even as well
as fan favorite Corsica we have new
modes for the photo mode as well things
like new filters we have new poses for
the characters we have stickers you can
place on the photos Now and Then There
are some extra hidden secrets that we
don't want to give away right now which
uh as you know from our game we like to
hide in there and we like people to find
which is always fun and then in
conjunction with this release we're also
releasing a separate uh costume pack
which is a kind of take on what the
characters would look like if maybe this
game took place in a different time
period oh a little tease I like that and
there's some really fun fun looking
stuff in there so well thank you again
so much for coming out all the way from
Japan to Showcase extended John I'm
super glad to be here that's all we have
to share about the new update for Tango
Gameworks is Hi-Fi Rush coming soon now